and it's so humbling to hear of their
sacrifice and I say it over and over and
over again and I will continue to say it
that we must live lives worthy of their
sacrifice the seventy one hundred killed
a Guadalcanal the two thousand three
hundred and thirty six killed a Peleliu
and all the soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines who as Robert Leckie said later
in his life who fought or who foremost
fighting fell and I think it's also
important to remember the example of
Robert Leckie who by his own admission
was no angel no plaster sinked but who
was truly a hero and remember that that
people all people have good and bad
qualities and people make mistakes and
they do dumb things and yet those very
people are capable of so much and yet so
often we judge
we judge and we judge and we judge and
we cast stones but but who are we to
judge who are we to judge when a man
like Robert Leckie lucky Leckie who not
only drank to excess and chase girls and
pulled a pistol on his superior officer
and who got so nervous so scared yes I'm
gonna call it the scared who got so
scared that he would lose control of his
bladder every time he went to sleep
and yet he overcame that fear with more
bravery in his heart than most of us can
even fathom so who are we to judge we
shouldn't judge people we should help
them then there's probably nothing more
we can do to live a worthwhile life than
to help people to help other people and
in helping other people I promise you
will be rewarded and you will be helping
yourself too and one more thing that we
see in this book once again is the
strength of human will we see
men tested beyond anything we can
imagine
and then when they passed that test one
time they get given that test again and
then again and still they overcome they
overcome the pain and the suffering and
the fear and yeah we can't get ourselves
out of bed in the morning we can't move
toward a goal we've set for ourselves
don't know how that remember the Tanner
rule River remember the airfield at
Guadalcanal remember the discipline
instilled in every marine at Parris
Island and remember what you you
remember what you are capable of if you
mobilize your will and if you keep
moving forward
you keep advancing remember what you are
capable of if you keep attacking and
keep attacking and keep attacking and
don't stop
don't stop moving forward and don't stop
attacking and don't succumb to the
suffering and the pain and the fear
don't succumb but instead move forward
and attack